comment créer des emplois comment
développer l'économie réunionnaise
comment améliorer la vie des personnes
âgées et des personnes en situation de
handicap
autant de questions soulevées dans des
ateliers qui ont fait l'objet de
propositions présentées lors de la
séance plénière du conseil départemental
dans l'hémicycle les élus de la
collectivité mais également tous les
directeurs et responsables des services
qui ont participé à ces échanges pour
faire émerger de nouvelles pistes de
travail pour les années à venir
la première déposition c'est la création
de maisons d'accueil on d'un million
pour pouvoir répondre à un besoin
universel âgées l'instant situation de
handicap social dans l'objectif des
partenariats privés les liens à la fois
vers l'emploi mais également je crois
c'est vrai les jeunes réunionnais ont
semblé dix maisons
dans un objectif préventif et le mois de
juin
nous avons travaillé en commissions
thématiques etc et vue on peut produire
effectivement de réflexion à partir
vraiment fourni par des services à
partir de ce moment là nous devrons
agréger toutes ces réflexions d'un
groupe vinci pour déboucher sur un
premier document de travail les
perspectives qui seront le socle du
projet de mandature de cette nouvelle
majorité il s'agit de trouver des
solutions mais également d'améliorer les
dispositifs existants qui répondent aux
besoins de la population réunionnaise
l'étape suivante finale sera l'écriture
politique le cul mans qui relève plus de
des spécialistes de la question donc le
cabinet et autres et donc d'ici fin
octobre le projet mandature sera élaboré
de manière définitive et sans doute
adopter
par les élus de l'assemblée
départementale le pompage brit air qui a
déposé des motions lors de cette séance
l'une qui vient soutenir la demande de
l'assemblée des départements de france
qui souhaite que le revenu de solidarité
active redevienne une compétence de
l'état
par ailleurs la présidente du conseil
départemental a mis en avant le problème
de l'aide ménagère obligatoire en
direction des personnes en situation de
handicap france adf a déjà sollicité le
transfert une financement l'insertion
comme levier de développement le conseil
départemental possède désormais les
éléments qui vont permettre d'établir un
projet de mandature au plus près des
attentes des réunionnais